so new game
chiliberto from the Philippines no from
Chile you could have thought yes D3
well
okay normal development should
be fine now he makes an active move
so now you could of course take G1
Rook G1 Queen H4 Chess G3 Queen H2
won pawns  I don't know if it
's a good thing, but it's
definitely complicated, let's take a look. Check, yes, now he has to play like that and now D H3, yes, probably, it
looks strange here somehow, but at least
I'm also picking up G3, which is
strange, okay with it  I didn't
count it now, which doesn't mean anything.
I had a bit of reservations about knight D5,
well, well, I'd rather cover up the
point
aha, okay, he lets knight D4 move
with speed ne
to queen F2, I have knight G4 then
it's a very short game  well okay
the move can't be bad
yes and
now
check yes it was worth
taking away the pawn on
H2
so I overlooked that again okay
taking the queen with check ca
n't be that bad like that and now it's better
not to set your own
like that  a queen for a
piece doesn't give up,
well, let's see that we can
get the box open as quickly as possible
with G6
right away, yes,
and he can't do anything
active either.
aha, well, I can't take that,
that's right, what
's wrong with that?  With Queen
H2
I should now win another pawn here with G3.
He has to play tur F,
I think
oh he doesn't have to, well Checkmate J that
went
quickly